-It's Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet".
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-All right.
Welcome to "WeTweet".
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that we should
post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you five
different tweets,
and we're gonna vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
Do you all have them?
All right, yep,
they're green and red.
Green is for go,
red if for stop.
You like it, green, good.
Red, you don't like it,
it's fine.
You can vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want, and we're
gonna see the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you have clickers, too.
-Got it.
-All right, whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out live
on the show so
that you can all like it
and WeTweet it.
-[Crowd] Ah!
-It's like a shared experience.
All right, are you guys ready
for this?
-Yeah!
-Whoo!
-The first tweet is...
[ Light chuckling ]
-Wow. All right, very good.
I can already...
-You can tell this is a big one.
-I can already tell you,
the band didn't play,
no one cared.
Yeah, you don't even have
to vote on this one,
I think I could see the --
The votes are in, let's just
look at the results.
Not gonna be good, yeah.
-Oh.
-That's what I felt, yeah.
You didn't like that one.
All right, no problem.
I guess people
like FaceTiming people.
-Yeah, they love it.
-Yeah.
This next one says...
[ Laughter ]
It's like wait,
am I my wife's jeans?
What is this?
They'll stretch out
in 20 minutes.
All right, let's see
the results.
I think these will be better
than that one.
Let's see. Yeah, a little bit.
-Not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right.
-Come on.
-Again, I want
to remind everyone --
these don't necessarily
get better.
Okay.
Here we go.
The next one says...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
That got a groan.
-Yeah, they liked that one.
-This one's gonna get high.
-People enjoyed that.
That one people enjoyed,
I think.
♪♪
All right, let's see
the results over here.
Whoa!
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's what I'm talking about.
All right, so now I know
the clickers work.
Now I know it works.
Yeah, here we go.
Next up, how about this one?
It says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
I can't wait!
Ohh! I'm so excited!
[ Laughs ]
All right, here we go.
Votes are in.
Let's see the results.
I feel good on this one.
Whoa!
-Whoa!
-Boom! Boom.
Boom.
[ Applause ]
-Whoa!
-This last one says...
All right, here we go.
Cast your votes.
I think we know
what it's gonna be.
I think it's Uber all the way.
But let's see.
I don't know, I could be wrong.
I think I know the audience.
All right, here we go.
We're done voting?
All right, let's see
the results.
There you go!
-Whoa!
-The winner is four, Uber!
That's the one.
[ Bell dings ]
I'm gonna post this during
the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a WeTweet, and enjoy.